of course we'd love for him to buy  Facebook and some of these other guys I  don't think he can go raise that kind of  money yet uh in the valley unless if the  valuation goes lower but I think he has  one other play he's got to do I really  think he's got one other play he's got a  major newspaper and he's got to finalize  CNN six billion dollars okay go buy  cnn63 scare the [ __ ] out of everybody  there if he pass on now what happens is  now he owns one of the virtual  governments which is Twitter and if he  goes buys one of the mainstream the  ultimate mainstream fake news you know  he buys CNN do you realize this is the  one way to actually get these people to  go to Canada  this would be the ultimate way to get  people to say you know what I'm finally  doing it